hello everybody and i welcome you all to
this online session to learn more about
the programs
about getting started with
bioinformatics in r and in python so in
this program generally we will discuss
about
how data-driven research is in life
sciences and and different opportunities
that come with analyzing or
understanding high throughput
technologies and the data associated
with high troop technologies and
computational methods various
computation methods that is used for
analysis annotation of such detailed
data in leading industrial and research
applications so we will discuss about
various data types different analytical
and statistical methods used for
analyzing and understanding the data and
the patterns in the data and also to um
and the impact of such analysis on
health care environmental sciences
public health and agriculture etc etc so
today let's learn more about the program
uh about uh
put the necessary tools that is required
for performing these analysis methods so
so i am raghavendran a bioinformatics
mentor from pine biotech and i'll be one
of your mentors throughout your journey
in this in this field of bioinformatics
and with our mixed logic
so as sonalika mentioned the goal of our
mixed logics program is to provide you
enough training in bioinformatics and to
enable you independent uh to perform
independent research guided by mentors
and by other peer examples we also
facilitate developing a growing
community with a sharing passion for
data-driven research and appreciation
for uh citizen sciences
so in these programs that you see and
the associated learning resources you
will
it's running
wait a second it's yeah
you will see broad applications of next
generation sequencing and you will see
applications of how biostatistics and
how tools for
some tools for these omics data analysis
are used uh in the environment of uh r
and in piping so the learning resources
resources will be focused on the logic
and the application of
data science methods for biomedical data
uh in programming environment like r and
also in python so uh
this will also provide you technical
in-depth review of coding with these
languages and
this will also help you in
with the help of practical assignments
you will be learning about how the logic
of bioinformatics and see how these
methods can be used to study biology in
general
so in in conclusion you will also be
able to plan how to take what you have
learned so far and apply it to an
independent research project using tools
methods we cover uh in the program
so we will review generally the concepts
behind common challenges in biomedical
data analysis that is finding signal in
noisy data sets and to find biological
explanation for the results we will also
see challenges and applications uh
challenges and opportunities to use
general statistical methods and advanced
statistical methods to find complex
molecular characteristics and patterns
that can be associated with the
genotypical conditions and biological
conditions that we can interpret
so
at the basis of
this uh there is so much interest in
data science from biology and from
medical community
these days and the researchers from both
the fields are gen and researchers from
bioinformatics and biology
field are generating massive amounts of
data and as any field that has huge
amounts of data people are interested in
what this data can offer so people like
people from data science methods can
can actually
perform this analysis purely from data
science perspective and understand the
patterns from the data so
this processes of
analyzing this data and filtering these
large data sets and produce meaningful
biological and medical insights by
application of statistical and machine
learning models and methods are actually
yeah are actually driving these results
and this research further so uh
in order to be able to uh succeed in
this in this research or in this
in the research of bioinformatics you
need not be expert in everything but you
should at least have some practical
experience in
in
in coding and in domain-specific data
processing and in
general uh filtering and data
transformation techniques and in
application of statistical uh basic
statistical and advanced statistical
methods and machine learning methods so
you should be able to uh understand
several different methodologies used to
analyze
big data or big or mixed data so
being able to write code or being able
to understand the code that is written
by others is is one of the one of the
most
prerequisite to proceed further and
understand develop a deeper
understanding in bioinformatics and and
data science methods what we get a uh
analysis so um
by the end of this program we will
enable you to understand uh different
methodologies that are discussed in uh
in the publication and to be able to
use understand codes that are available
and with the associated uh publications
and and also uh being able to
generate or being able to develop your
own code for
for the analysis of
next generation sequencing data
so this field as we know has developed
tremendously in the last several decades
transforming life sciences and enabling
uh biomedical research so as a result we
have many new discoveries and uh most of
these discoveries uh are the result of
generation generation of large amounts
of comics data
that includes phenomics data genomics
data epigenomics and different omics
data from different
molecules that characterize the cells of
organisms so many of these omics data
can be generated using next generation
sequencing methods or which is also
known as high throughput sequencing
numbers the data here
show a detailed information about
genomic variants about the patterns of
the gene or patterns of the gene
expression isoform expression and
different
[Music]
molecular characteristics of the cell
that can be associated with the
phenotypical or biological state of the
cell that we are studying
so
in order to explore further with the
with um
with the programming environment we will
take variety of the such examples excuse
me my computer is not responding yeah we
will take variety of research
examples and and learn about the logic
behind each steps and
each of these types of using our mix
data or big data to study
cancer tissue biology and microbiome for
example in
in
in some of the project and
associated project examples that we are
going to discuss with in this program
so
basically
as a as we had
discussed already there is a tremendous
amount of our mixed data that has been
generally generated but most of these
generated methods of generated data has
been is is unstructured so one of the
challenges of converting or one of the
challenges of
applying different machine learning
methods and machine learning different
data science methods and the analytical
methods is to convert these unstructured
data into structured data so uh
for to enable this uh this conversion of
or to enable generation of the
structured data from these unstructured
data
uh we also have several other programs
and several other uh
courses that deals with how
structured data can be generated from
genomics data and social genomics data
transcriptonics data and etc etc so once
you have structured data and and
we can
use uh a programming environment or
coding environment like uh ah
python to uh understand or to um
getting started with the
excuse me yeah uh getting started with
uh with understanding the logic or
coding skills that you need to
try and uh
learn about the patterns that are
that that are buried deep into the data
so we can uh
go over this in in in the associated
lessons and most of the lessons and
resources are structured in uh in these
six
structured structure
ladder so first we have to understand
the problem of what we are going to deal
with and then we learn the code so we
will go over this in uh
by
by exploring some of the lessons and
and go over this step by step but in
general each of these lessons are
structured as this so we we will just we
will make you
familiarize with the problem or the
statement or the aim of the lesson and
then we will help you in understanding
or in learning the code that is
necessary to perform these analysis and
then we will also help you to
learn
key
parts or key syntax elements of the code
so that you can modify the output or you
can modify the method that will suit or
that will make you or enable you to
appreciate the kind of analysis that is
performed on the structured data and
then we will also have a
different try to try it out yourself
section where we
give you a code block with
missing syntaxes or with incomplete
codes so uh from from the learning that
you had
acquired from learn the code section you
can apply it to these areas and to these
code blocks and then successfully run
the code and thereby enabling a deeper
understanding of this coding and then
this also
helps you to modify some of the aspects
of the code and then get
more clearer picture or give a practical
uh
hands-on experience of understanding the
code and then in the end we also give
you uh
a much more detailed and much more
elaborate assignment where you will you
where you are expected to not only to
complete the syntaxes but modify few of
the syntaxes and apply it to a different
dataset for example or apply it using a
different methodology
so that you can gain an appreciation for
the uh core uh core lessons that you
have learnt so far so this is the
structure for both r and python and
gain my depth
so uh this has several topics and this
linked with uh and is also linked with
uh example data sets using um
example data sets that are
properly i mean that are carefully
curated um for um
curated from various research domains
like cancer or infectious diseases and
uh etcetera etcetera so yeah
so we also provide a comprehensive
experience in uh
in in an introduction to data science or
machine learning methods in in r and
python using uh r and python and so you
will also
enjoy
uh getting introduced to different
machine learning tools and statistical
analysis tools and how you can apply
that to various omics logics various
omics data so to understand
the patterns and to understand the
general
biology behind the data
so
each of this lesson as i mentioned comes
with a practice console and you can
use it right in the browser so you don't
have to go out of the browser
environment to practice these
codes that you are that we have learned
so far
so
first
as i mentioned in learn the code section
you will be learning about the logic the
syntax and
here in this practice console you can
test your understanding with hands-on
experiences
and hands-on exercises so as this video
just mentions you just complete the
instant taxes and then
click run to generate the output and to
verify that you have
successfully completed the challenge so
that
you can gain a deeper understanding of
the code that is
so in this in the in the next section
breakdown you'll also learn about the
objective and and strategy for any a
given method and then you will also see
and you will also
see how the code or how to code
code for a solution or code for for a
problem by learning the syntax and
testing your understanding with
assignment and coding languages so in
the end of a python lesson for example
you will be given or given access to a
collab notebook or on an interactive
notebook which you can modify or which
you can
use to
use to
analyze for for a different data set or
for modified data set or for modified
methodology so that you not only
run or not only try to run what was
given in the lesson but also you can
expand your understanding in in this
coding uh
environment in in general
so each of this
collab notebook will also be
supplemented or will also be in will
also include
assignments and these assignments can as
i mentioned
can be comprised of
modification of the methods or applying
this methods of different types of
methods to
different data sets or a same data set
comparison of the
comparing the output and gaining some
biological insights and you can submit
these assignments to us by completing
this
this
assignment uh
given at the end of the collab lessons
so in the end generally you will be able
to take the structured data that you
generate from uh from a sequence of
sequence
of analysis pipelines to understand uh
to apply to different areas of
biomedical research like uh
clinical like uh phenotypic and other
different areas of environmental
research
so as as i mentioned we will
we will start from very basic uh like um
how to understand how to load
how to load
a file in an environment like r and
python
and
we will slowly build up the complexity
of your
programming
requirements or programming knowledge
and then in the end we will help you to
uh run necessary statistical analysis
necessary exploratory analysis and
different statistical analysis so that
you can
discover patterns in real data sets that
are used in the publications and used in
the researchers to study and understand
uh molecular phenomena or biological
phenomena at different levels
so uh
yeah this we already spoke about these
this includes
basic coding challenges like
loading data from uh from your computer
that is in different format like in
comma separated format or on txt format
or or even excel sources and
you have to place these loaded
data into different data structures and
you will gain a much more
detailed um understanding of what these
data structures and how
and what are the different structures
that we are going to use to analyze on
its data so this you can perform in both
in r and python and we have a parallel
uh
coding um
lessons and program running for both uh
r and python and um
as i mentioned uh all of these coding
lessons are actually organized with with
plenty of comments and with plenty of
descriptions so that each and every part
of the syntax is actually uh discussed
so in the end at
the culminating end of this program
where you will be
explained or you will be given access to
uh
access to model projects and example
projects where we uh take the curated
dataset or where we take the dataset
that is used in publications like this
and curate this dataset to apply uh
either this
similar uh statistical methods or
different uh data science methods uh
that can be applied to the
curated data and then the patterns
within this data can be
understood or can be uh
studied too related to phenotypical
characteristics like drug response or
like
like
different um tumor stages or different
patient certification etc etc so this is
not the only example projects that we
will be discussing and by gaining access
to the
learner mix logic platform you will also
gain access to different example
projects that we have generated or we
have
we have
developed for your deeper understanding
of
bioinformatics methods from
different omics data types so let's
quickly